yo um obviously coming into the game
with a song like Panda I want to say
drewski put me onto that record
my voice
he had to be one of the first guys
you know Bobby Tran shake the block yeah
but it's crazy because that record was
like such a movement out of New York
City right and then you end up on good
music a version of that song ends up on
uh you know the life of Pablo which is
one of my favorite yay albums when did
you first like initially find out yay
was gonna use part of panda on
the life of Pablo oh man like bro when
we was over there in the city and be
driving
we just came you know it's 11 label been
and we'll be going crazy everyone's
trying to sign you yo everybody's yellow
on the tables are going crazy
being a taxi cab over here is a call
like yo you ain't want to do something
with the record you know what I'm saying
now my lawyer he like
and you know I think you want to do
something with the ad-lib or something
like you for me like you want three
dollars
long story short he like yo let's fly
out to LA he tell us to pack up go to
L.A we go out there yo bro I'm over
there like that whole day you know what
I'm saying I was like suddenly you're
just pulling up you know y'all see us
jumping out the car he just in the car
he just had the record right there for
us like you for me let's like yo you
like this
oh my God that that's your five you know
what I'm saying at first you know what I
mean and I thought he was gonna go
longer I ain't know like you know I mean
he just was gonna put like you know he
just put like probably like six bars on
it right but I'm saying so I ain't
I ain't like you know I thought bro was
going he was just like nah I'm gonna
just let you go crazy bro and I was like
yeah that's fine yeah or then he was
like I'm on my way out he was that's
when he was messing with Kim
and then you ended up signing with good
yeah after that you know what I'm saying
word that night you know I mean we was
in the studio me and him Mike Dean we
was over there all cooked up it was like
Mike Dean was working on [ __ ] for the
weekend and then I just was pulled up
it's playing music he was making music
and it was like yo we know we got a sign
bro his energy out of here like
and then we just informally we made a
move was there ever a point in time you
regretted signing with good because you
had you could assign with anybody
um yeah definitely worked for me I um
many people try to sign me man that's
what I'm saying even you chose Kanye
probably over everybody because at that
time that record was so cool no you know
what I mean you know what I mean like it
was different like you told me like and
obviously there was like the highs of
the good music situation but obviously
they were the lows and that's not just
for you as an artist there's a lot of
artists that we're all good that like
you know probably deserve more attention
yeah it worked you know what I'm saying
it was a it was a lot of people that
were trying to sign me and the reason
why I'm saying that you know I mean
because you know some artists that's you
know other artists that tried to sign me
as well you know what I'm saying well
yeah this is you know who else try to
sign you that like who was the closest
besides yay that you were that you were
looking at in terms of just like
potentially signing with other artists
other artists Ross MMG
anybody out of New York bad boy
oh Coke Boys Coke Boys that would have
been crazy and um that was real you know
that [ __ ] for real for real bro every
time I see you it's a movie man and
that's the reason um it was a couple
artists no man well there's a couple
artists though my boy French I ain't
gonna say all the artists but it's no
that's no French yeah French French is a
great CEO too man yeah salute to him
recipes to chinks